nous allons à présent ouvrir une page
culture avec nos prochains invités deux
festivals l'un dédié à la musique
l'autre à la bande dessinée vont se
dérouler ce week end dans les yvelines
juste avant les images de la répétition
de la compagnie bulles de zinc pour les
journées du patrimoine qui a company qui
prépare un rendez vous insolite à lise
casting nous l'expliquent c'est parti
histoire du lieu où comment noyer le
poisson
cette compagnie de théâtre nantaise va
nous faire redécouvrir saint quentin en
yvelines lors d'une visite pour le moins
atypique entre histoire et humour on est
dans plein de registres différents
moi j'aime bien changer de registre à
chaque spectacle est celui là c'était
d'aborder la ville sur un ton
humoristique de relire la ville sous un
angle absurde
en mêlant le vrai il faut donc nous on
vient sur le site sur la ville on se
renseigne sur l'histoire du lieu
double titre on prend un personnage qui
a existé dans le passé mais qu'est
ignorer ce personnage c'est l'abbé
picard à l'origine de la construction
des canaux qui ont servi à alimenter
versailles au xviie siècle
comment se laver et faire ça le cir
quand on a
cinq visites gratuites sont organisées
samedi et dimanche à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine
alors rendez vous devant le musée de la
ville à montigny pour tenter de démêler
le vrai du faux
deux festivals se déroule donc ce week
end je vous le disais il ya quelques
instants un festival de bd du côté de
crespières et nous recevons pour en
parler corps une ruelle chargé de
communication sur ce festival bonsoir
est également clair bigard qui est
dessinatrice très vous avez dessiné la
fille justement de ce festival qu'on
verra à l'image vous l'avait ramené mais
on va la voir aussi s afficher et puis
l'autre festival dont nous parlons tout
à l'heure c'est le festival magnifique
bonsoir à jérémie bosse lui une soie et
bonsoir un an gilles guilbert donc vous
travaillez tous les deux sur
l'organisation de ce festival dédié à la
musique aux arts de rue au cirque
également vous allez nous donner tout le
programme on va commencer par là la
banque dessinée
le festival de crespières c'est le plus
grand des petits festivals c'est michel
blanc-dumont notamment connu pour
blueberry qui a dit ça c'est un honneur
vous attendiez justement à devenir le
plus grand des petits festivals est ce
que ce titre vous convient oui
parfaitement
est ce que vous vouliez vous avez quand
vous avez fondé le festival quelle était
l'idée derrière justement l'idée c'était
qu'il ne soit pas trop trop loin
justement qu'ils soient confiées à l'air
comme volé non non non pas du tout mais
qu'ils soient connus et que l'on ait du
monde
et que ça reste vraiment sur le plan
familial convivial
l'idée c'était quoi c'est une histoire
de passionnés ces deux passionnés au
départ en 2005 qui ont créé ce festival
et c'était juste après le festival
brassens qui avait lieu à crêpière et il
y avait des dessinateurs et justement ça
a tiré les dessinateurs et ils ont eu
l'idée de justement de le créer
donc depuis 2005 en 2005 nous avons eu
sept cent cinquante visiteurs et là on
en attend plus de 3000
qu'est ce qui a changé entre 2005 et
aujourd'hui justement sur le festival la
même recette vous avez modifier des
choses non quand même pris un peu
d'ampleur en termes d'implantation des
intrigues l'ampleur la deuxième année je
crois ce qui nous a vraiment propulsé
c'est la venue de jacques martin
dessinateur très connu à lille alors
cocardières justement vous en êtes
installé à crêpière ben moi j'habite à
crépir depuis trente et quelques années
on vous n'êtes pas venu spécialement
pour le festival
non moi j'habitais sur place en fait
vous étiez ravi alors j'imagine de voir
la création d'un festival dont ça a été
tout à fait un hasard en fait au départ
j storyboarder dans le cinéma pendant gc
ca 20 ans et je suis venu à la bd tout à
fait gentiment va dire puisque j'ai fait
des bd tout seul dans mon coin sans que
personne ne sache au départ est
l'organisateur du festival en 2004 2005
quand ils commettent commencé à mettre
sur pied le festival a eu vent que je
faisais effectivement une bd dans mon
coin donc il est venu me voir et puis
après il m'a dit il faut absolument que
tu montres tes planches au dessinateur
qui vont venir en l'occurrence michel
blanc-dumont que j'ai rencontré
justement la première année et qui m'a
fortement encouragé à continuer donc
c'est le festival a créé bière qui vous
a permis ensuite qui vous a lancé en
tout cas je remercie daniel à gazinet
effectivement qui est toujours mon
mentor qui se charge de faire la
publicité ma promotion dans beaucoup de
festivals et maintenant à charge de
revanche chez lui ramène des
dessinateurs parce que je vais boire
dans beaucoup de festivals ce qui me
permet moi de ramener des gens maintien
crépiat pour que ça continue a invité
d'honneur et oui c'était cette année et
vous allez présenter
alors cette année j'ai reçu
a notamment particuliers non pas du tout
enfin ça c'est les deux premiers tomes
que j'ai sorti donc endémique il ya
méprise méprise on va en voir l'une des
couvertures voilà qui va s'afficher à
l'écran ça c'est les deux tomes que vous
êtes sur lesquels vous avez travaillé on
va voir la couverture et puis il y en a
et une autre au cias et les nouveautés
que je sors cette année justement au
sein du festival très bon hugo risi
s'affiche excusez moi et puis après on
va voir justement le casque d'agris ce
qui va s'afficher également et les
quelques planches qui en était tirée là
la sortie sera faite au moment du
festival - le sertit la crêpière voilà
officiel puisque la bd est sorti le 12
décembre le 12 septembre pardo en
international à loquace quant à gries
voilà et puis les quelques planches donc
vous avez aperçu tout à l'heure ce
festival justement voulu se positionner
comme ans par rapport aux autres par
rapport à angoulême tout à l'heure qu'on
a évoqué alors c'est bien qu'ils étaient
comme ça des petits festivals aussi
gravitent autour d'angoulême tout au
long de l'année oui je considère que
chrétien n'est pas un petit festival en
terme de notoriété le grand bain retiens
c'est un moyen pour nous maintenant
parce que moi je suis invité à des plus
petits que ça et disons que très bien
maintenant commence à devenir dans les
moyens c'est bien quand même important
maintenant on n'a aucun intérêt
effectivement à organiser comme saint
malo ou angoulême
parce que d'abord on n'a pas la capacité
de recevoir très honnêtement on est une
petite commune de 1500 habitants donc on
n'a rien à voir avec une grande ville on
n'a pas les subventions que draine un
festival comme angoulême
mais en même temps il faut reconnaître
quand même que c'est un festival qui vit
grâce à des sponsors bon département
bien sûr et à la mairie qui nous aide
mais surtout par des sponsors
donc contrairement à certains gros
festivals qui eux sont soutenus par des
maisons d'édition nous narre par contre
on n'a pas ce phénomène bien ça nous
agiter un petit peu là vient tout de
même la ville le petit village qui est
devient un centre d'intérêt pendant le
week-end et justement donc on est une
équipe d'organisateurs
magazine il s'appelle bo d'un françois
amigues arbres et d'autre et une
trentaine de bénévoles donc et des
crêpières lois qui vont être présents
qui vont venir à huy se mobilisent et en
plus ce week-end il y aura un peu de
bruit puisque on aura le samedi après
midi de dimanche après midi un défilé de
harley davidson v parce que la
thématique on l'a pas précisé mais la
thématique de cette édition 2012 s'est
auto moto voilà c'est pourquoi alors il
ya beaucoup de motards parmi eux ou deux
titres individuels son festival conçu
pour vous fait pour vous sur monsieur à
cette édition de ce travail aussi dans
le monde de la moto est effectivement je
rejoins là les deux pôles d'attraction
pour moi la moto il descente alors quand
vous voyez justement que sur ce festival
qui aujourd'hui est devenu un festival
moyens voilà on va le situer comme ça
qui a évolué c'est dû à quoi aussi c'est
dû au fait que la bande dessinée attire
aussi de plus en plus de monde
alors rien il ya un engouement ce moment
c'est la bande dessinée il faudrait faut
préciser qu'on est passé dans le
neuvième art ya pas très longtemps donc
effectivement moi dans tous les
festivals où je vais il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui sont intéressés et
toutes générations ça ça me fait plaisir
c'est compris dijon ça m'aidait vous la
voyez comment s'il ya une évolution dans
le style ces dernières années ce que ça
a changé un moment où il ya une
concurrence avec les les bandes
dessinées japonaises et manga on parlait
plus de la bd classique franco belge
et moi je vais vous parler aux tourments
de situation je vais vous parler de ce
que je ressens de ce que je vois est ce
qu'après d'autres dessinateurs doivent
avoir le sentiment différent
moi je pense d'abord que la bd à tous
ont admis encore qu'on n'arrivera jamais
à accepter le numérique la lecture sur
sur écran parce que nos acheteurs sont
fanatiques du toucher ils veulent palper
ils veulent changer voilà donc ces gens
là pour eux c'est un objet de collection
et je pense que moi mon ressentiment
personnel c'est qu'on en vient des
méthodes traditionnelles
même au niveau des dessinateurs
maintenant on est un petit peu moins
tentés de travailler sur ordinateur
rendu numérique n'a certain qu'ils le
font mais sur les gens avec qui je parle
des fois ils ont une envie de revenir au
pinceau de papier le neuvième art qui a
encore de beaux jours devant lui
festival de crespières ce week end le st
10 le dimanche avec des dédicaces rendez
vous des collectionneurs aussi des
exposants qui seront présents ce défilé
l'un des animations maquillage journée à
six en moto je pense le programme
complet sur le site internet justement
du festival du côté du festival
magnifique alors y'a pas de bande
dessinée par exemple la seule chose qui
nous manque c'est complémentaire
spéciale pour une prochaine édition
pourquoi vous allez nous donner par
contre tout le programme dans un instant
on va juste faire une petite pause on va
sortir de ce plateau quelques instants
pour se rendre à maurepas
il y avait le festival coup d'état le
week-end dernier dimanche dernier en
tête d'affiché
hubert-félix thiéfaine et nous y avons
croisé également jauni et montreuil un
pur rockeur rencontre coup d'état samedi
dernier à maurepas évidemment
l'événement n'a rien de politique
il s'agit en fait d'un festival musical
organisé sur le stade du bois par une
association avec à sa tête francisco
star le directeur adjoint du café de la
plage que nous avons rencontrés dans
l'espace vip
francis costes à sa plus simple que tu
me tutoie dans le rock il faut savoir
constitue à tous
mais maintenant aujourd'hui style est
ici c'est réservé aux artistes
donc ici tu es malade nous confirmons la
plage voilà c'est bien une piscine juste
à côté
et donc il ya des loges tu vois et il se
retrouve en échange gauche et puis on a
même
le du massage la masseuse jeunes qui
m'est coupé et chouchouter les artistes
parmi les artistes en question
hubert-félix thiéfaine le groupe
arcisien deportivo ou encore johnny
montreuil un lot issu de la formation
princes chameaux style directement
inspirée par l'esprit 20 zones noires
des années 60
oui j'ai débuté ma faim un chameau
l'était avant voilà c'était le groupe on
a on a expérimenté des chaussées les
premiers textes les premiers trucs qu'on
faisait de la zique un peu
instinctivement il n'y a pas vraiment de
style moussa emprunté à plein de choses
il y avait là johnny montreuil a déjà un
truc beaucoup plus directrices avec une
grosse influence de johnny cash les
adaptations qu'on fait lui c'est parti
d'un projet de jeu les montreuil donc
des textes carrément d'autres je me
cache réadapter complètement adapté
librement adapté on va dire bilan de
cette première édition du festival 1500
spectateurs soit 1000 personnes de moins
que prévu qu'ils organisaient
tenant faire les comptes et se lancer
dans la recherche de nouveaux
financements s'il peut voir de nouveau
faire bouger mon retard